[Musique]
la vie reprend son cours mais très très
lentement
yahoo
aujourd'hui on n'écarte pas du tout la
possibilité que ces attentats reprend ce
soir al qaïda qui ont soit responsable
[Musique]
le témoignage du général dallaire va
s'étendre sur des jours peut être même
des semaines la poursuite veut extraire
chaque petit détail de son expérience au
rwanda quand il a été un témoin direct
du génocide
la bombe a explosé hier et la poussière
n'est pas près de retomber
l'arrestation de guy cloutier pour crime
sexuel fait parler tout le québec fiq
l'outil n'a émis aucun commentaire et la
firme de relations publiques qui le
représente affirme qu'il n'y en aura pas
non plus on a eu la sentence michel donc
trois ans et demi de pénitencier pour
guy cloutier et six mois pour la
première victime 16 mois pour la
deuxième
trois ans et demi déchirant que cette
communauté la vienne vivre dès qu'on a
entendu les deux premières explosions au
tout début des combats
les gens ont compris que ce qui se passe
est très grave le président de
l'autorité palestinienne monsieur yasser
arafat est décédé cette nuit et ça vient
d'être confirmée par les autorités
palestiniennes à ramallah
[Applaudissements]
ça viendra ici et à plus de 31 mille
personnes sont venues assister à ce
match tristement historique il faut le
dire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cellou québécois denys arcand et son
film les invasions barbares qui ont volé
la vedette
le césar du meilleur réalisateur est
attribué à denys arcand pour les
invasions barbares toute ma vie dure je
me suis endormi avec les plus belles
femmes